F ALL, H HPLAYOFFS.
BREAKAWAY FROM THE BLUE LINE AND
LINE.
FAKSA TO THE FOREHAND IN FRONT
FOR KIVIRANTA, COULDN'T REACH
THE PASS.ZONE.A BEAUTIFUL READ
RIGHT ACROSS
GLENDENING CHASING.
CAN'T GETTUT BY ROBERTSON
>> Greg: SUTTER HERE DOUBLE
SHIFTING HIS BIG LINE A COUPLE
OF TIMES LATE
>> Greg: BACKLUND 59% LAST GAME
BUT HE LOSES THAT.
EVIDENTLY IT WORKED BECAUSE THE
FLAMES GOT THE
AS RYAN SUTER BRINGS THE PUCK
TOWARDS HIS OWN BLUE LINE. TIME
PAVELSKI LOOKED LIKE HE HAD THE
ENTIRE TOP OF THESHIFT.
BACKLUND LONE MAN UP AS TKACHUK
GOES TO THE HOPPER CORRALED
CALGARY LEAD!
THEY COULDN'T SORT OUT THEIR OF.
HE'S UNDER PRESSURE FROM BENN
WHO GETS THE PUCK JUST INSIDE
POSSESSION.
HANIFIN NOW THE LONE MAN ENSUES.
GUDBRANSON WILL GET BACK FIRST.
ROBERTSON COMES IN, CRASHES IN
NOW WE'RE GOING TO GET A STARS
KEVIN SAID, THEY FLIP IT
LOOK IN THE FIRST 13 SECONDS OF
THE
CHRIS TANEV...
WITH BIG MOMENTS. ON THE ATTACK.
WHAT DOES HE DO HERE?
HE BEATSMAN.
STARS BRING IT OUT.
FAKSA WILL DUMP IT IN.
BEHIND THE NET.
NOW ZADOROV BANKS IT AROULUND O.
HERE'S A CHANCE.
MANGIAPANE WITH GU
MANGIAPANE NOW SNEAKS TO THE
MIDD
HE'LL TURN IN HIS OWN ZONE AND
IT ALL SEASON LONG.RE'S LEWIS R
ANGLE, SCORES!
MAKES HERE!
FIGHTS, FIGHTS, FIGHTS!